zu glauben man kann mit Algorithmen
einem Problem gerecht werden dass
Menschen meinen im Internet andere
Menschen bedrohen und beleidigen zu
können das funktioniert so nicht da
braucht man wirkliche echte Menschen die
sich konkrete Fälle anschauen aber was
was ändert sich dadurch dass Elon Musk
jetzt Twitter gehört was ist denn die
Menschen können ja wer möchte und kann
ja sich äußern dort
muss man ja sagen na ja völlig
rechtsfrei was dort veranstaltet wurde
wie Verleumdungskampagnen stattgefunden
haben was was dort Leute über andere
Menschen erzählen und so das ist ja
nicht so dass jetzt Elon kommt und aus
diesem Ort jetzt plötzlichen ganzen
schreckensort Macht der vorher kein
schreckensort war das war ja schon
sozusagen das Problem existiert ja schon
lange mit Twitter aber Moment mal ich
muss ja ein bisschen in Ordnung bringen
wir können ja eindeutig zeigen und das
Beobachten ja auch viele UserInnen User
im Moment die um ihre Plattform Kämpfen
auf eine durchaus berührende Weise dass
sich das Kommunikation einmal gerade
jetzt radikal verändert also es gibt
Indizien dass der die Leugnung des
Menschen gemacht und Klimawandels
zunimmt dass die in Desinformation zu
Pandemie zunimmt all dafür gibt es
deutliche Hinweise wir haben auch gerade
in den letzten Jahren gesehen übrigens
belegt durch Studien wie ungeheuer
gefährlich Desinformation für westliche
Gesellschaften ist wir haben in Zeiten
der Pandemie ganz konkret erleben können
dass das Information in einem sehr
konkreten und direkten Sinne tödlich
sind tödlich ist wir haben sehr konkret
und direkt erlebt dass das Information
spaltet Populisten Auftrieb gibt
Gesellschaften unterminiert und
unterspült und letzter Satz letzte
Bemerkung wir haben auch erlebt dass das
Information uns bei der Krisen
Bewältigung blockiert wir haben
gewaltige Krisen die Klimakrise die
Pandemie andere die auf diese
Gesellschaft zu wollen und die nicht so
nötig machen wie globale Kooperation
wirkliches miteinander transnationale
Kooperation und genau das wird Durchgang
wird unterspült durch eine neue Macht
von Desinformation und mask steht für
eine Öffnung und weiter um das
kommunikativen Raumes quer zu dem
Gesetzen die in diesem Land gelten er
lässt Meinungen zu als Meinungen die
schlicht und einfach Schmähung sind und
deshalb ist es hier eine Veränderung die
am Beispiel zu diskutieren ist
[Musik]
also
ich glaube wir sollten uns mal wieder
für gegenwärtigen das ist ja ein
Unterschied gibt zwischen der
Meinungsfreiheit wie wir in Deutschland
haben und der freedom of speech in
Amerika denn der Schutzbereich von
speech viel viel weiter wir haben uns in
Deutschland damals dagegen entschieden
Tatsachen Behauptungen unter den Schutz
des Grundgesetzes zu stellen sondern die
haben gesagt die Schützen nur Meinungen
Meinungsfreiheit und hier fallen eben
zwei verfassungssysteme aufeinander ist
davon überzeugt dass jede Tatsache erst
einmal behauptet werden darf und da
haben wir einfach unterschiedliche
Systeme und wir sind in letzter Zeit
nicht gut darin gewesen unser System zu
verteidigen wir haben immer geglaubt wir
könnten mit kleinen runden und
freundlichen runden Tischen ein Konsens
mit Facebook und Google und Twitter
finden und wir sehen doch hier bei Elon
Musk ganz klar das muss durchgesetzt
werden rechtsfreier Raum ich muss dann
immer lachen weil faktisch haben wir
einen rechtsverfolgungsfreien Raum wir
sehen einfach das Twitter damit
durchkommt und das Bundesamt für Justiz
nicht ein einziges Bußgeld gegen eine
einzige Plattform in den letzten Jahren
verhängt hat und das ist wirklich sehr
bedauerlich was denken Sie woran das
Lied weil die Gesetze sind ja da es gibt
dieses
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetzes absoluten
im Internet
ich habe 14 Stunden vor mit dem
Prozessbeginn in Frankfurt erfahren
durch eine nächtlichen Schriftsätze
Gegenseite das Twitter die Erlaubnis hat
sich über das Netzwerk
durchsetzungsgesetz hinwegzusetzen dass
also eine stillhaltevereinbarung
getroffen worden ist dass kein
gegenvorstellungsverfahren durchgeführt
werden muss also da hat man halt eine
Absprache getroffen und gesagt gut
dieses Gesetz setzen wir auf Eis denn
ähm bis das gerichtlich entschieden ist
ob das wirksam ist oder nicht dann ist
ja sowieso der DSA da ich glaube das
ist ja kein Geheimnis gesagt hat wie
machen das lieber auf europäischer Ebene
das ist aber unabhängig von dem Besitz
von allen Musk das war auch vorher schon
ein Problem
das war schon vorher das Problem
ist wie wichtig ist Twitter eigentlich
Frau kam wenn man sagt das ist ja nur
ein kleinerer Teil der Bevölkerung ist
es einfach viel zu ja überschätzen wir
das auch und ist es vor allen Dingen
interessant weil er eine Maske auch als
Tesla Chefin interessante Figur ist und
natürlich auch einfach auch noch andere
ja also sehr mächtig
es ist deshalb auch so wichtig jetzt
oder sagen ist es eigentlich überschätzt
ich glaube Twitter war schon immer
wichtig und relevant ist es nicht die
allergrößte Plattform gewesen aber sie
war universell universell darin dass ein
denk austauschen Informationsaustausch
auf dieser Plattform anders
stattgefunden hat als auf anderen und
zuerst Beurteilung zum Austausch mit
Expertinnen und Experten mit
JournalistInnen Journalisten und auch
mit der Politik das hat woanders nicht
so funktioniert und deshalb ist es eine
ganz ganz besondere Plattform die auch
schon vorher eine besondere Relevanz
hatte wir benutzen Sie es so sagen sie
da ist Twitter für mich echt wichtig
deshalb bin ich dann also mich erreichen
Bürgerinnen und Bürger natürlich
irgendwie per Mail aber ganz oft
schreiben Sie mir auch eine
Twitter-Nachricht also öfter als bei
Instagram wo habe ich dann als Bürger
oder als BürgerInnen die Möglichkeit
direkt mit einer PolitikerInnen
Austausch zu treten wenn ich mich
austauschen möchte mit Experten und
Experten zu einem ganz spezifischen
digitalpolitischen oder in politischen
Thema dann kann ich das machen ich höre
und lese ganz schnell Position zu
aktueller Tagespolitik das ist
einzigartig und deshalb auch ganz ganz
wichtig und deshalb macht es auch einen
Unterschied ob Twitter vorher schon in
toxischer Raum war und das das kann man
vielleicht auch so sehen bestimmt da
gibt es auch genug Studien aber es wird
eben schlimmer und aber Frau Funk sie
haben selber auch gesagt ich mache da
nicht mit ich bin bei Instagram und
nicht bei Twitter warum also ich habe
ich war nie wirklich aktiv bei Twitter
ich hatte einen Account und dann habe
ich den aber wirklich schon vor zwei
Jahren zweieinhalb ich weiß es ehrlich
gar nicht ehrlich gesagt gar nicht genau
oder sogar schon drei Jahre ist das hier
den Account gelöscht weil die
Kommunikation die dort stattgefunden hat
ich als wirklich also ich kann das nicht
mal als Kommunikation bezeichnen ich
halte das wirklich von total furchtbaren
Ort ich finde aber auch das ist in
Ordnung ist wenn Menschen an diesem Ort
unbedingt sein möchten und kommunizieren
wollen das ist nicht meine Form zu
kommunizieren
und ich habe Twitter verlassen und und
bin eben selbst trotzdem auch Opfer von
Verleumdungskampagnen auf Twitter
geworden ohne dass ich dort war und habe
natürlich mitbekommen was das bedeutet
wenn dort irgendwelche Tatsachen
behauptet werden und so ja also ich
glaube auch nicht also ich halte auch
Twitter wirklich nicht so wichtig ich
glaube das Twitter in den letzten Jahren
vor allem von den Medien viel zu viel zu
sozusagen aufgebauscht wurde und auch zu
wichtig gemacht wurde wir haben es dort
mit einem unglaublich kleinen Teil der
Gesellschaft zu tun ja wir haben also
wirklich nur 8 Millionen Twitter konnten
also was sind 8 Millionen Twitter
konnten in Deutschland davon sind ja
wirklich wahrscheinlich die Hälfte
überhaupt richtig aktiv das heißt da
diskutieren irgendwie 4 Millionen
Menschen ähm und was sind also was was
sind 4 Millionen Menschen die
diskutieren in einem in einer
Gesellschaft in der 80 Personen
existieren also und da sind ganz
bestimmt auch eine es gibt ganz
bestimmte ganz bestimmte politische
Agenten die auf Twitter durchgedrückt
werden und es gibt sozusagen bubbles die
kreiert werden die sich gegenseitig
unterstützen und auch dabei helfen zum
Beispiel dann eben
irgendwelche
empörungsaufregungen zu kreieren und so
das hat ja auch ganz viel das ist ja
eine ganz spezielle Dynamik die auch bei
Twitter die bei Twitter sozusagen ja
auch ausgelöst wird
wie wichtig würden Sie sagen wie wichtig
ist Twitter für die Meinungsbildung in
unserer Gesellschaft wir müssen immer
auf Deutschland ist also aus meiner
Sicht ist Twitter trotz dieser ja
relativ kleinen Nutzerzahlen
außerordentlich wichtig sie können sagen
es ist so eine Art Nachrichtenkanal für
jedermann es ist eine Möglichkeit
Menschen sehr direkt zu erreichen sie
haben es gerade geschildert es ist auch
und das sage ich jetzt als
Wissenschaftler ein wunderbares
Recherche also ich tauche eigentlich
jeden einzelnen Tag ein in Erkenntnis
und Forschungsgemeinschaften bekomme
sofort Materialien entlegenste Art
Aufsätze zugespielt bekomme auch die
Möglichkeit es ist mir in der Pandemie
so eindrücklich vor Augen geführt worden
gewissermaßen die Welt durch die Brille
eines Virologen einer virologin und zu
betrachten und zu sehen was wird da im
Moment tatsächlich in diesem in diesem
Moment der Unruhe diskutiert also ich
halte das Medium für sehr sehr wichtig
wir erleben es auch jetzt im laufenden
Ukraine Krieg wie militärexpertin und
Experten Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer
unterstützen das hat auch was sehr
berühren das also ich würde die
Plattform auch nicht absolut absolut das
schafft eine ganz andere Nähe und zum
Teil eben auch Empathie also ich würde
eigentlich sagen dass auf Twitter trotz
dieser vielen toxischen
kommunikationsverhältnisse die wir
beobachten ist eben auch diese
Gemeinschaften gibt die wirklich einen
Erkenntnisprozess miteinander
erleben und treiben und auch durchaus
respektvoll oder sich fördernd
miteinander umgehen das ist das
erstaunliche eben und deswegen ist es
Ringen so groß und ist auch die
Enttäuschung so groß viele Menschen
erleben das jetzt also eine kalte
Enteignung jetzt wird sozusagen ein
neues Klima das so vorher noch nicht da
war erstmal gesetzt aber dann könnte man
ja sagen es ist ja jeder Freitag damit
zu machen denn man könnte die könnten
doch den was denn entgegensetzen also es
wird ja niemandem verboten sich dazu
äußern Politik war ja vorher eine andere
Jack Johnson hat sehr viel
genauer verstanden wie gefährlich das
Information ist hat sehr viel striktere
moderationspolitik Betrieben Elon Musk
ist ins Twitter Hauptquartier eingezogen
kurios Gewalt sie können es auf Twitter
sehen hat er einen Waschbecken vor sich
hier getragen und danach hat er die
Hälfte der Belegschaft gefeuert
das ist das was passiert ist und unter
anderem auch also
das ist beschäft
igt seit Jahren gesprochen wird das hat
ja schon bei Tesla so gemacht das macht
er in seinem in seinem SpaceX mask hat
eine ein sehr speziellen Führungsstil
den kann man kritisieren das kann man
schwierig finden aber das ist jetzt
nicht da ist da passiert jetzt nicht
etwas was anders ist als es vorher war
und als anders als mask in sein
Unternehmen die er geführt hat agiert
hat er feuert er lässt Leute rund um die
Uhr arbeiten das ist sozusagen das ist
sein Style und wie gesagt das kann man
schwierig finden aber das ist er bringt
sozusagen sein Führungsstil den er bei
Tesla so lebt und den er bei SpaceX so
lebt den bringt er jetzt eben zu zu
Twitter und ich will mal eine Sache noch
mal sagen zu bitte er hätte ja nicht
verkaufen müssen an Maske niemand hat du
hast ihn gezwungen
42 Billionen Euro zu verdienen
unter die Frage ist es ein Unterschied
wenn wenn es um eine Autofabrik gibt
geht oder eben um einen um eine
Plattform die für unsere Demokratie
wichtig ist das würde ich ganz gerne sie
auch noch mal fragen wie wenn man was
macht was für ein Unterschied ist es
dass das eben Twitter jetzt allen Maske
gehört und nicht irgendeiner
demokratisch gewählten Institutionen
wäre das überhaupt geht es überhaupt
eine Alternative Frau kann also es ist
natürlich ein Unterschied es machen
Unterschied ob ich ein Unternehmen
schlecht führe oder ob ich eine soziale
Plattform vielleicht führe und da
vielleicht dafür Sorge mit dem Argument
hat mit dem Argument der
Meinungsfreiheit
ein Haufen Mitarbeiter kündige also was
bedeutet das für die IT-Sicherheit der
Plattform das bedeutet meine Daten wenn
ich nicht sicherstellen kann dass er
nicht übermorgen liegt ist und meine
persönliche Kommunikation oder andere
persönliche Daten plötzlich in der Welt
sind also das befürchten sie konkret das
ist jetzt und das Problem gibt mit
selbersicherheit weil es eben viel mehr
mit viel weniger Mitarbeiter jetzt gibt
genau also er hat er hat relativ große
Bereiche also kündigt Mitarbeiter und
der IT-Bereich ist auf jeden Fall einer
also die Sicherheit ist so nicht mehr
gewährleistet und wenn ich aber
argumentiere mit Meinungsfreiheit und
dann aber nicht verstehe das Content
Moderation auch dem Bereich sind ganz
viele Leute gekündigt gekündigt worden
in relevanter Faktor ist um die
Meinungsfreiheit überhaupt erst zu
institutionalisieren dann habe ich ein
Problem nicht verstanden aber wollen wir
nicht mehr darüber sprechen dass er
einfach ganz normal rechtmäßig sich
dieses Unternehmen erkauft hat ne er hat
das ja rechtmäßig einfach gekauft er hat
das ja nicht dass er keine Diktatur er
hat das ja nicht eingenommen oder so der
Bäume darüber sprechen dass diejenigen
die den Twitter gehört hat die haben
alle Twitter User und alle Mitarbeiter
in genau diese Situation gebracht in der
wir jetzt sind kein Elon Musk das stimmt
aber kann trotzdem nicht machen was er
möchte er hat sich an Recht und Gesetz
zu halten Moment das tut er ja ja
natürlich würde ich ihre Meinung gern
auch noch mal zuhören was das für ein
Unterschied ist wenn er da Twitter
eigentlich gar keine Rolle wem Twitter
gehört und es steht uns auch nicht zu zu
entscheiden wer das kaufen darf oder
nicht darf denn jedes Unternehmen muss
ich an Rechnung Gesetz halten das ist
jetzt irgendwie eine Phrase dir schon
mehrmals gefallen ist und das ist
eigentlich offenkundig aber wenn wir ein
Unternehmer ein Management haben was
nicht von sich aus intrinsisch motiviert
ist sich an Werte oder Gesetze zu halten
dann muss man halt als Aufsichtsbehörde
auch mal aufwachen und ein bisschen mehr
auf die Finger schauen und nicht als
alleine den amerikanischen
Aufsichtsbehörden überlassen also hier
ist jetzt wirklich die Bundesregierung
gefordert solange das
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz noch bis
20-24 gilt regulierend hier einzugreifen
und dann überhaupt keine Entfaltung
Aktivitäten machen sie mal konkret was
fordern Sie ganz konkret jetzt von der
Bundesregierung von Bundesjustizminister
dafür zuständig was fordern Sie da und
was welche Möglichkeiten gibt es da
überhaupt
also das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist
ja dafür eingeführt worden um
durchzusetzen und da gibt es die
Möglichkeit mit Bußgeldern von bis zu 50
Millionen Euro gegen Unternehmen
vorzugehen die zum Beispiel systematisch
die moderationspflichten Verletzen man
war da sehr vorsichtig hat gesagt nicht
wegen einem einzigen Fehler sondern wenn
man sieht da gibt es eine Systematik die
sehen wir wir sehen ganz genau das
überall dort wo falsch Nachrichten oder
Personen verbreitet werden Verleumdung
über Nachrede das Twitter dort nicht
einmal den Sachverhalt aufklärt im
Gegensatz zu Google übrigens die das
besser machen auch sogar Facebook
mittlerweile man könnte sofort reingehen
und dort ein Bußgeld verhängen man
könnte natürlich Ermittlungen anstellen
aber es wird anscheinend nicht einmal
mehr angehört also wir sehen jedenfalls
nicht das Twitter sich unter Druck
gesetzt wird im Gegenteil man schließt
stillhalte Abkommen also man hat das
Instrumentarium nur nutzt es nur nicht
aus anscheinend wartet man auf die
Europäische Kommission aber das dauert
noch anderthalb Jahre genau weil das
Netzwerk durchsetzen würde dann ersetzt
durch das europäische durch den Digital
serviceakt der aber erst 20 24 glaube
ich letztendlich in Kraft tritt richtig
richtig wir könnten jetzt noch wir
müssen jetzt noch was wir können ja
nicht einfach warten bis die Kommission
sich da in Position gebracht hat wir
haben das Gesetz sie haben es auch am
Anfang ernst genommen aber die letzten
zwei Jahre haben die ganzen
Plattformbetreiber gesehen oh das meinen
die gar nicht so ernst das war hier eher
ein symbolischer Art es gibt kein
einziges Bußgeld nicht ein einziger Euro
jedenfalls für die systematische
Verletzung der moderationspflichten und
da müssen wir ansetzen weil Twitter man
kann den Fernbleiben es mögen auch nur 8
Millionen Account sein aber es prägt die
Art wie wir unsere Meinungen bilden und
das kriegt dann das was auf der Straße
stattfindet also ich halte es für
hochgradig gefährlich und wichtig dass
diese Plattform sichern Richtung Gesetz
hält was wir er wäre dann aber eine
Alternative wenn man sagt man das
gefällt mir dann doch nicht wie das da
passiert es gibt ja auch genug Leute die
jetzt sagen ich verlasse Twitter was
bedeutet das es gibt also Mastodon ist
ein eine Plattform die anders
funktioniert Frau kann ist das ein Punkt
wo sie sagen okay dann gehe ich eben
dahin ich bin auch bei Mastodon
tatsächlich bin auf beiden Plattform
aktiv und sie haben ihre Vor- und
Nachteile jeweils
machst du dann ist
datensparsamer es gibt kein Algorithmus
der mich irgendwie vor der Posts
vorsortiert in Deutschland gegründet es
ist ein es ist auf Open Source Basis ich
kann
ich will nicht zu technisch werden aber
ich kann dafür sorgen dass bestimmte
Blasen einfach nicht mich erreichen oder
ich sie nicht erreiche wenn man einzelne
Instanzen hat es ist auf jeden Fall
eine Alternative es ist aber nicht das
Gleiche also wenn man erwartet ein
Twitter ein klein zu bekommen dann ist
das vielleicht das dass man kriegt aber
auch nicht mehr als das
wie sehen sie ist das jetzt einige dann
sagen wir gucken mal ob wir eine andere
Möglichkeit haben gibt es überhaupt eine
andere Möglichkeit gibt eine Alternative
zu Twitter ja es gibt natürlich
Alternativen sie haben es gerade erwähnt
das wird ausprobiert ich persönlich bin
nicht sicher ob machst du dort wirklich
funktioniert denn sie sehen also jemand
der ein paar Millionen voller hat auf
Twitter zieht dann um zu Mastodon hat
vielleicht jetzt wie ein Böhmermann
66000 Follower immer im Moment wir
wissen aus den entsprechenden Befragung
80 mit der Deutschen wissen gar nicht
was machst du denn ist das Problem von
hate speech ist nicht gelöst dass sie
haben diese 4000 dezentralen Server bei
Mastodon aber in dem Moment und das ist
ein interessanter Befund in dem eine
Plattform eine gewisse Größe erreicht
kommt eben auch das Problem von Hass
Hetze Diffamierung aber ein
Gesichtspunkt will ich doch noch
einbringen ich war in den letzten beiden
Jahren intensiv im Silicon Valley
unterwegs und habe so die Uhr und
Frühgeschichte der ersten sozialen
Netzwerke studiert und da sehen sie im
Grunde genommen das Erfolgsgeheimnis für
ein gutes kommunikationsklima und das
heißt intensive Moderation eine relative
klar Kleinheit
eigentlich Verzicht auf Data Mining also
ein Grundproblem ist auch das machen die
permanente Ausbeutung der Userinnen und
User zu kommerziellen Zwecken
absolutiert werden und
diese diese Kombination von Abo Modellen
intensiver Moderation relativer
Kleinheit die ist durchaus ein
Modell über das sie sich noch mal ganz
neu nachdenken zuletzt das Gute an dem
an der jetzigen ja an der jetzigen
twitter-krise ist ja das noch einmal
Gesellschaft vor Augen geführt bekommt
was ist möglich und was läuft schief in
der ganz neuen Direktheit in gewissem
Sinne ist die Figur von Maske auch das
hat so interessant weil sie in ihrer
Hoheit in ihrer Gewalt in ihrer ganzen
macht
in einer Person zeigt was schief läuft
also die Lösung kann deshalb glaube ich
auch nicht sein zu sagen wir finden eine
andere Plattform wo wir uns vielleicht
glücklicher zu Hause fühlen sondern es
ist ein strukturelles Problem und es
braucht deshalb auch strukturelle
Lösungen wenn man es will gesetzlich und
die Gesetze sind ja da genau und da da
wollte ich mir auch ganz kurz ein
ergänzen also das Netzwerk
durchsetzungsgesetz hat ja in einzelnen
Punkten der konkrete Paragraph ist 3 ähm
verfassungsrechtliche Probleme und
Schranken vorgesetzt bekommen also dass
man da dann nicht weitermachen kann ist
klar es gilt auch trotzdem aber der Rest
also es ist ja nicht so als wäre das
Ganze netz.de aus dem Fenster geworfen
sondern die Paragraphen wo man
gerichtlich gesagt bekommen hat da sind
jetzt unterschiedliche Plattformen
gerade unterwegs und dagegen zu klagen
und so lange greifen oder werden die
eben auch nicht durchgesetzt und da
gibt's dieses stillhalte Abkommen an der
Stelle ist aber auch nicht unüblich
sondern einfach ein Regel riesiges
Verfahren aber wir sind ja schon länger
unterwegs in diesen sozialen Medien und
wir merken dieses Hass Hetze die Art wie
da kommuniziert wird ist ja anders als
wenn wir auf dem öffentlichen Marktplatz
sind das wissen wir ja alle vor wenn sie
nicht na ja ich glaube was wichtig ist
wir reden auch viel über
Falschinformationen also
Falschinformationen gibt es schon so
lange wie es den Menschen gibt und
Falschinformationen haben auch die
letzten Jahrhunderte wirklich
Informationskampagnen gesteuert noch mal
aber ja es gab auch falsche
Informationskampagne die zu dramatischen
historischen Ereignissen geführt haben
dafür brauchten wir keine netzwerkwerke
ja also Hexen sind wegen falsch
Informationen schon verbrannt worden
Juden sind ermordet worden wegen
Falschinformation also dass Menschen
Behauptungen Ideen Fantasien in die Welt
setzen und ähm durch durch Gruppen
Gruppenbildung diese Ideen zu Wahrheiten
stilisieren und aufbauschen und damit
gesellschaftliche Veränderungen und auch
schrecklicher Ereignisse lösen das haben
wir also vielleicht wäre es wichtiger
nicht die ganze Zeit über diese Symptome
zu sprechen wie einen Netzwerk wo 8
Millionen Menschen sind sondern sich
eigentlich zu fragen was braucht der
Mensch ja der Mensch sozusagen in seiner
Existenz mit seinen Eigenschaften was
muss bei uns bei Menschen passieren dass
wir zum Beispiel lernen
Falschinformationen zu erkennen es
braucht da eine es braucht eine Bildung
weil das ist ja sozusagen nur ein wir
haben es jetzt ja nur mit einem mit
diesen Netzwerken zu tun die die die
spiegeln ja nur unser Mensch sein wieder
da passiert ja nichts was nicht nicht in
unserem sozusagen in unserer Existenz
sowieso schlimmer sagen
mir ist lieber zu lesen was plötzlich
irgendwie ähm einen Christian aus
Hannover 53 über den und denkt als wenn
also das Wissen darum wie Menschen über
andere Menschen reden das wissen auch
darum wie Menschen über Menschengruppen
sprechen das ist das ist ein wichtiges
Wissen das hatten wir ja lange Zeit so
gar nicht weil es weil das wird es
dadurch schlimmer wird es dadurch eben
befeuert ich das ist die das ist eine
Frage ob es befeuert wird aber sie gehen
ja auch nicht weg die Netzwerke werden
nicht weggehen es wird ein neues
Netzwerk geben wenn man ein bisschen
länger auf der Welt ist wir haben alle
mal angefangen mit MySpace jetzt sind
wir irgendwann bei Twitter es wird auch
ein neues Netzwerk geben auch es wird
auch etwas geben was nach Twitter kommt
ein soziales Netzwerk nach Twitter ja
und wir müssen uns aber viel mehr damit
beschäftigen wie können wir Kinder und
Jugendliche ähm besser bilden in Bezug
auf Falschinformationen auf das was im
Internet passiert
vielleicht wollen wir doch mal darüber
sprechen was die Möglichkeiten sind denn
das netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist ja
nicht das einzige was wir an
Möglichkeiten haben vor 100 Jahren fing
der Straßenverkehr an und da braucht man
am Anfang auch keine Regeln und
Netzwerke sind jetzt da und die werden
auch bleiben und wir müssen vielleicht
auch mal einsehen dass wir vielleicht
ein paar mehr Regeln brauchen zwar nicht
nur strafrechtliche regeln wir haben
nicht das Problem beim
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz dass wir nur
bei strafbaren Inhalten anfangen obwohl
es viel viel mehr Sachen gibt die z.B
niederschwelliger auf der Ebene von
Bußgeldern auch geahndet werden könnten
ich glaube wir brauchen eine Diskussion
dass wir die Art wie wir miteinander
kommunizieren auch mit Regeln versehen
Regeln sind zwar nicht Sex das macht
keinen Spaß und viele würden sagen lass
uns lieber die Freiheit und den die
Vernunft des Menschen darüber
entscheiden wie wir miteinander reden
dort wo Menschen auch durch ja Geräte
geraten brauchen wir bessere Regeln und
zwar auch kleinere Regeln also eine Art
Ampeln wie im Straßenverkehr
genau okay wie könnte das aussehen haben
Sie eine Idee
ja also wir haben das Problem dass wir
kaum Ordnungswidrigkeiten tatbestellen
also wir bräuchten eigentlich ein
Bußgeldkatalog für die Sachen die noch
nicht strafbar sind oder wo die
Strafbarkeit vielleicht noch einen
weiteren Kriterien hängt wie zum
Beispiel die Verbreitung von solchen
falsch Nachrichten mit den Menschen
gefährdet ein ganz konkret in sozialen
Netzwerken wird in letzter Zeit immer
wieder empfohlen kleinen Kindern klar
dioxid Tropfen zu geben so viel bis sie
brechen um im Schäden oder im Wirkungen
auszuleiten das ist totaler Unsinn und
wirklich gefährlich aber es ist nicht
verboten so etwas da verbreitet werden
und ich glaube wir sollten bei solchen
Kommunikationsform tatsächlich überlegen
ob sowas nicht besser mit einem Bußgeld
garnet werden kann vielleicht ein
anderes Beispiel
ist aber dann schwierig wenn man sagt
wir wollen Meinungsfreiheit haben das
ist ja gerade vielleicht noch absolut
eine aber meinungsfrei wie vorhin schon
gesagt schützt ja Meinungen okay
Bemerkung dazu das rechtes sicher ein
ganz wichtiges Instrument aber es ist
vielleicht das letzte Instrument und
vorher gibt es noch sehr viel im Diskurs
in Aushandlungsprozessen und auch in dem
Feld der Bildung und der Erziehung also
für mich ist Medienbildung eigentlich so
etwas wie angewandter demokratieschutz
und wir sehen wir haben eine laufende
Medienrevolution vielleicht vergleichbar
mit der Erfindung der Schrift oder das
Buchdrucks mit beweglichen Lettern und
wir sehen wie ungeheuerliche
schwerfällig und langsam das Schulsystem
reagiert es macht mir große Hoffnung
dass zunehmend in Deutschland so eine
Art Graswurzelrevolution der
Medienbildung entsteht nämlich aus dem
Journalismus kommt das Journalistinnen
und Journalisten die nichts anderes tun
als Fakt und Fiktion zu unterscheiden
und sich zu überlegen was ist
veröffentlichungsreife überhaupt
vertrauenswürdige Information des die in
die Schulen gehen und Schulen besuchen
und da Workshops geben das sind sehr
sehr wichtige aus meiner Sicht Hilfen
Leitplanken denn ich sehe es nicht ganz
so wie sie soziale Netzwerke sind und
wir haben die entsprechenden Studien die
zeigen sind wirken in ungeheuriger Weise
verstärken ich will ihn mal ein
konkretes Beispiel nennen von Facebook
negativ verstärkt und manchmal auch
positiv verstärkt im Sinne der
politischen Partizipation also Kollegen
hier aus Berlin von Max-Planck-Institut
haben gerade eine Metastudie
veröffentlicht haben mal knapp 500
Studien durchgeguckt und sehen ganz
genau welche Infekte gibt es und was
lässt sich belegen und was nicht aber
ich nehme immer ein ganz konkretes
Beispiel von Facebook 2017 Donald Trump
wird
vereidigt hat sich mit Facebook
nachweislich an die Macht gepöbelt 150
Millionen Amerikanerinnen und Amerikaner
haben negativ Posts vom Kreml finanziert
gesehen Hillary Clinton ist kriminell in
diesem Jahr verdient Facebook 16
Milliarden gewinnen vor Steuern in
diesem Jahr wird auf Facebook die erste
Kuh an und Gruppe gegründet in diesem
Jahr werden wird auf Facebook zum zu
Ermordung der horinja aufgerufen in
Myanmar dieser muslimischen Minderheit
und man findet leider keine Zeit um
diese hasspostings zu beseitigen und hat
insgesamt drei Mitarbeiter die irgendwo
in Dublin sitzen von denen man nicht
weiß ob sie überhaupt sprachmächtig und
landeskundig sind um diese hasspotics
Postings zu dechiffrieren und man hat
keinen Mitarbeiter vor Ort und
gleichzeitig geht facebook-Chef Mark
Zuckerberg nach vorne und hält eine Rede
wie großartig ein Kilometer lang esse
auf Facebook publiziert wie großartig
uns Facebook alle verbindet das ist die
Situation also massives Geld für
einzelne Unternehmen gleichzeitig
Ignoranz von Hass aufrufen die zu
unmittelbar die unmittelbar und
nachweislich zu Gewalt führen und zu
Spaltung ganze Gesellschaft auf der
anderen Seite ist es natürlich auch
genial so ein Instrument wie Facebook zu
erfinden und es sind ja ist ja die Frage
wir nutzen ist ja alles der Erfolg also
die Menge an Menschen die darf auch mit
Whatsapp Instagram unterwegs sind zeigt
ja auch dass es ein großes Bedürfnis
danach gibt und das ist ja eigentlich
dann an sich nicht so schlecht sein kann
das ist ja auch interessant also ich
würde auch damit nicht sagen also um
Gottes Willen keine
technologieverteufelung man kann sagen
Technologie ist nicht gut nicht böse
nicht neutral aber sie wirkt
verschärfend und das ist der Punkt
eine Sekunde
mit einem anderen Vorschlag in die Runde
kommen Bildung ist natürlich ein Faktor
Medienbildung aber
wir im also wir als Ampel haben im
Koalitionsvertrag den Vorschlag der
plattformräte noch definiert das sind da
geht's dann quasi um den Bereich der gar
nicht justiziabel ist aber immer noch
ein problematisch und der findet also
dieser Rat könnte einfach ein relevanter
Faktor sein zur Verbesserung der
Situation könnte vorschreiben oder
vielleicht
Interpretationshilfen leisten in dem
Bereich könnte
Angebote liefern was die Algorithmen
angeht die müssen sowieso transparenter
gestaltet werden und also diese Geräte
würden funktionieren ehrlich für
Rundfunkgeräte und wären dann quasi auch
in einem Äquivalent also bereit sein
aber wenn das nationales Gesetz ist dann
ist das nationales Gesetz also ehrlich
gesagt gab es auch schon Diskussion ob
man das beim digitale Dienste gesetzt
auf europäischer Ebene anwendet das hat
man nicht gemacht aber auf nationaler
Ebene kann man das immer noch machen und
dann ist das natürlich auch eine
Grundlage an der man sich orientieren
müsste sondern kommt auf die
Zusammenstellung an am besten
Wissenschaft betroffenen Organisationen
Menschen die sich auskennen mit der
Technik im Hintergrund und dann legt man
da einfach auch in irgendeiner Form
Regeln fest
die wollten noch was sagen
Antworten zu dem Aspekt der Bildung ist
großartig allerdings erreicht
Schulbildung natürlich nur einen sehr
sehr kleinen Teil der Menschen viele
sind aus der schulischen einfach durch
und wir müssen aufpassen dass wir mit
einem Vorschlag den wir sozusagen
alternativ in die Runde werfen nicht die
anderen beiseite wischen weil auch die
Idee mit den Räten das Recht ist
natürlich nur ultimate so völlig richtig
aber müssen dran gehen alle diese Hebel
zu ziehen weil kein einzelner Hebel das
Problem alleine lösen kann und insofern
dürfen wir da einfach nicht locker
lassen und uns nicht davon einlullen
lassen das eine kleine Lösung die aber
schwer zu erreichen ist das problemlos
und alleine wirken sollen ich würde mal
gerne auf wir haben jetzt viel über
einen Maske gesprochen aber wir haben ja
auch
Saka work wir haben Jeff Bezos also das
sind ja drei sehr mächtige Männer wenn
man so haben die zu viel Macht der Boxen
ich würde sagen ja
ganz merkwürdiges paradox der digitalen
Zeit auf der einen Seite eine
gigantische Öffnung des kommunikativen
Raumes jeder kann sich zuschalten und
das ist erstmal eine wunderbare
Nachricht weil auch viele Menschen auch
das gehört zu einem gerechten Bild eine
Stimme bekommen die vorher keine harten
und auf der anderen Seite haben wir eine
totale macht vermachtung das
kommunikativen Raum ist ganz wenige ja
die wie Feudalherren in der alten Zeit
agieren ich nenne ihn mal eine einzelne
Zahl in diesem Jahr werden drei
Unternehmen mehr als die Hälfte aller
Werbeeinnahmen weltweit für sich
vereidigen können auf sich zu lassen
52%, das ist Google das ist Meta bzw
Facebook und das ist Amazon gleichzeitig
erleben wir und das ist
demokratiepolitisch ein gravierender
Verlust wieder Lokal und Tageszeitung
Journalismus in diesem Land und in
vielen anderen Ländern der westlichen
Welt stranguliert wird weil ihm die
Werbeerlöse weg schwimmen und weil er
kein ausreichendes Geschäftsmodell hat
und diese vermachtung von Öffentlichkeit
die muss einen beunruhigen und die
nebenbei bemerkt die beunruhigt auch
manche der der
plattformunternehmer selbst ja die sind
ja die die gucken ja sehr interessiert
nach Europa das kann ich nach diesen
Reisen durch Silicon Valley wirklich
sagen ich guck sehr nach interessiert
nachdem was machen die mit dem
netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz da was
machen die mit dem Service die warten
eigentlich auf die Regulierung um die
Zerschlagung zu vermeiden durchaus auch
strategischen Gesichtspunkten
durchaus gesagt das ist Punkte gibt bei
allem was die das ja als Visionär
gearbeitet hat bei den anderen bei Jeff
Base ist bei Max ackerberg das Menschen
wo man sagt die haben einfach was
umgesetzt solche Figuren gibt es eben in
Europa in Deutschland
also die haben auf jeden Fall so viel
umgesetzt dass wir hier heute sitzen uns
uns und uns über die unterhalten und und
wie wir angefangen haben ja auch die
Diskussionsrunde zu Beginn
Milliarden von Menschen sind sozusagen
auf diesen sozialen Netzwerken und
kommunizieren miteinander oder bestellen
bei Amazon oder was auch immer also das
hat die haben selbstverständlich unsere
Gegenwart zutiefst geprägt und ganz viel
geschaffen und ich finde das auch in
Ordnung dass auch herauszustellen und zu
sagen da ist unglaublich viel
enormes kreiert worden was uns zu dem
Punkt gebracht hat wo wir heute sind und
das bringt aber eben auch
Schwierigkeiten und auch demokratische
Schwierigkeiten und gesellschaftliche
Schwierigkeiten mit sich was mir noch
mal wichtig wäre auch zu sagen wenn wir
die ganze Zeit über Regulierung und so
weiter sprechen selbst Personen die sich
dann im Unternehmen in dem Unternehmen
das Netzwerks befinden und dann dort zu
gucken sollen was muss denn jetzt
gelöscht werden und was nicht das sind
doch auch nur Menschen die haben
politische Position die haben eine
Einstellung die haben die haben Ängste
die haben die haben Sorgen wie kommen
wir denn auf die Idee den dann die Macht
dafür zu geben zu regulieren was richtig
und was falsch ist Kriterien genau
deswegen müssen wir kontrolliert werden
sie müssen dann noch mal kontrolliert
werden genau und wenn wir gesät und dann
und nur noch mal nur und man macht dann
Gesetze und dann und das funktioniert ja
wunderbar wenn wir in einer liebevollen
Demokratie leben aber wir haben ja auch
eine AFD z.B was ist wenn die plötzlich
eine Bundestagswahl gewinnt und und ein
Land führt und mit Gesetzen agiert mit
Gesetzen agiert die z.B existieren also
wir reden über über Idealsituation wo
dann gesellschaftlich alles noch in
Ordnung ist aber was ist wenn wir
sozusagen politisch an einem Punkt
kommen der zum
unsere Demokratie und keine Gesetze mehr
keine Kriterien ich sage nicht was die
Folge ich will nur sagen
dass wir darüber nachdenken müssen dass
wir aus Idealsituation heraus
kommunizieren und wir gehen von von
Menschen die Frage ist für mich immer
was ist das von Menschenbild zu glauben
da da können könnte man Leute
positionieren die sagen dann äh das muss
gelöscht werden das unter die haben dann
recht und die anderen
machen können
auch eine Diskussion sollte man Facebook
so viel Macht geben zu entscheiden was
gelöscht wird oder nicht aber wir haben
keine Alternative dazu wir können nicht
alles zu Gericht schicken sondern wir
sagen das sind die Regeln und danach
werden diese Entscheidungen begründet
und überprüft genau diese Regel die
Twitter nicht umsetzen wollte das
gegenvorstellungsverfahren wir brauchen
genau solche Instrumente damit diese
Menschen auch wiederum die kontrolliert
werden bzw die Maßnahmen danach zum
Beispiel von einem Gericht überprüft
werden können das ist nicht ideal aber
es ist das Beste was wir haben also
vielleicht da noch eine Ergänzung diese
Plattform Rede die Sie ins Spiel
gebracht haben und die hat tatsächlich
auch im Koalitionsvertrag 19 sind auch
deshalb so interessant weil sie genau
eine Instanz und Institution sein
könnten um Transparenzpflichten zu
erzwingen sie haben ja recht niemand
soll auf irgendeiner Hinterbank
Entscheidungen treffen für Milliarden
für Menschen sondern aber
einschätzungsfähig zu werden als Userin
oder User gefällt mir eigentlich die
Politik meiner Plattform da könnten
solche Transparenzpflichten und solche
plattformräte durchaus hilfreich sein um
uns mit dieser Runde dazu beigetragen
etwas mehr Transparenz zu schaffen
vielen Dank Frau Funken und Frau Kahn
für die Diskussion ihnen vielen Dank
fürs zuschauen sind schon wieder am Ende
aber wir bleiben auch noch ein bisschen
bei Twitter können Sie uns folgen weil
für bei Phoenix und auch ganz normal im
Fernsehen sehen und jetzt folgt Phoenix
der Tag bis morgen tschüss
[Musik]
[Gelächter]